[Music]  we are an unusual couple  it was really so fun getting to play all  these different decades  throughout juan division we just don't  know what to expect  and then of course everything kind of  breaks down and becomes an  mcu version of the real world am i dead  no why would you think that because you  are can't believe how it just keeps  unraveling  and unfolding in ways that i am still  shocked and thrilled by  every day it's something different you  know it's high-tech marvel with  helicopters flying around  and the next day it's a perfect  recreation of a 50s sitcom you know some  days it's it's both  i think something's wrong here  i think it's gonna be really satisfying  for people when they realize  what is at the heart of this show this  is our home  then let's fight for it  you